hey welcome back to my channel my name's
samuel leeds i'm a property investor and
i've become quite successful
investing in property i started with
nothing
and over 12 years i've built up a
multi-million pound property portfolio
i've had a lot of tenants have a lot of
issues i've also had a lot of good
things that have happened
so once a week i think it's really
important to for me
who's been there done it to answer
people's questions that may be just
getting started or maybe
just a year or two years in so if you've
got
property investment questions this is a
great opportunity for you to ask
your questions so how does this work all
you need to do
is comment your question in the comment
box below
and then what i'm going to do is i'm
going to try my very best
to help you in your specific question
and you might be just getting started
maybe you dream to build up a property
portfolio maybe you're planning on
defining your first property investment
this year
or maybe you're going to set up a
business like a rent-to-rent business or
a deal sourcing business
whatever it is comment below in form of
a question
and i'll do my very best to help also
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
turn the notification bell on i don't
think there's a
youtube channel in the united kingdom
which
talks as much about real estate and
property investment as i do on this
channel so
if you want more tips and constructive
ways of growing your property business
then subscribe and also
drop a like on the video that would be
much appreciated as well
so let's see what questions we had from
last week's video
as i'm answering these questions if you
have a question or an offshoot to a
question
just whack it below and i'll do my best
to answer so we've got
hi samuel would you recommend buying an
apartment
for the purpose of renting it out as
serviced accommodation this is by 1985
waza so yeah i would recommend doing
that
service accommodation is when you rent a
a property out
as a hotel so you're going to list it on
places like airbnb
booking.com if you buy an apartment with
the view
of renting it out as a as a mini hotel
basically
that's going to give you much much more
cash flow than if you just rented it out
to a normal single person or a young
couple
so i would say it's a good idea the
things to bear in mind number one
make sure that there's no restrictions
on the
mortgage lender so the mortgage lender
you're getting needs to know that you're
doing that and also there's no
restrictions on the head
lease what i mean by that is when you
buy an apartment usually it's in an
apartment block
and there might be a restriction on the
apartments that you can't rent it out as
short stay let so just check that
um also really importantly is
you whenever you're buying a property
you need to look at the best case the
likely case and the worst case
now if you're buying an apartment with
the view of renting it out as a service
accommodation
unit you need to say well what's the
worst case well the worst case is that i
can't rent it out
they changed the rules there's some
issue so
the worst case would be i'd need to rent
it out
as a single letter if that happened
would i still be making money so what
what do i mean by that i mean you need
to have an exit strategy and the exit
strategy needs to be
renting it out as a single let um so if
you're buying an apartment
to rent out a service accommodation just
have an exit strategy that says if that
doesn't work
and i end up just sticking somebody in
it a young couple will i still make
money and if the answer is yes
then i don't think there's any reason
why you shouldn't do that so i hope that
helps
okay next question from trexam
says can you sell a house with a
bridging loan against it just thinking
about exit strategies thanks alan
um alan you can sell a property with a
bridging loan against it
however nearly every lender
that provides bridging loans will
require to have a
charge on the property now what that
means is that when you come to sell it
you can't get any money from that
property sale without first
paying back the bridging lender so let's
say you own a property you bought it for
100 000 pounds
and you've got bridging of 50 000 pounds
which is alone
there'll be a charge on the property you
can sell the property
but only if there's enough money in the
sale
to pay back the bridging company
otherwise you will be liable for the
shortfall
um so the answer is yes but just make
sure that
you can pay them back up on the sale
before any money goes to you
it's going to go to all of the charges
first
okay darren i found a plot of land
with japanese knotwood on it the person
selling the land has a quote
of 60 000 pounds to rid
the land of it the land itself is going
for 265 000 pounds
and it has planning for nine houses and
the gdv
is 2 million do you think it's worth my
time
any tips on raising the finance on such
a project if you think it's
worth it great question so listen i'm
only going to be able to go with the
information that you've given me and of
course i can't say
yes buy it or no don't buy it without
knowing more details
but for what you've told me if you can
buy it for 265 and it's going to cost 60
grand to get rid of the japanese
knotweed
that's basically the the upfront
acquisition costs
um nine houses it all depends
on how much it's going to cost to build
the nine houses
it sounds to me that there's quite a lot
of profit there because
two million pounds gross development
value
it all i can't answer it without knowing
what the houses are
what the spec is and how much it will be
to build the houses but
definitely worth pursuing and feel free
to drop me a message on instagram and
and maybe we can we can speak more
great okay hi samuel can you give an
example
of how much an investment would be for
beginners
that say it's too expensive to do now
example
rent to rent hmo okay i
think your question is how much
money do you need as an initial
investment for beginners to get started
i think that's your question i hope i've
understood
correctly to answer that question
you don't need anything to get started
or or you could you might need if you're
the last guy
that was talking about the piece of land
then then you might need a quarter of a
million pounds
it look to get started in property
you can either set up a business
like rent to rent like you've said as an
example
or deal packaging if you're going to set
up a business
you're not investing money in property
you're
starting a business that is going to
make money and generate profits using
property as a vehicle now if you're
doing that
how much money do you need to start a
business well you don't need any money
to start a business
you can if you're creative and you might
say but samuel you do you need money to
set the setup company's house there's 15
pounds to set the company up
you need money to get the contract you
need money but you can
you can if you if it's a business the
whole purpose of a business and as an
entrepreneur
is that you've got to be creative and
find win-win solutions and problem solve
for example when i started my business i
started
renting out people's rooms as a
management company
i didn't i was a sole trader i just said
i'll rent your rooms out for free
and i charge the tenants the 90 pound
admin fee went to me
how much money and then it grew i just
started growing and then started doing
rent to rent and deal packaging
so you don't really need any money to
start a business
you need a lot of other things you need
courage
knowledge you need um
time creativity but you don't need
money so if you're wanting to get
started in this business
in the business of property um you know
you could
if even two three four thousand pounds
can go a long way when you know what
you're doing and when you're prepared to
put the time in so
i hope that helps and i hope i've
understood your question
stunt fretchy frenchy says can i move
up in house can i move up in house but
keep my current one
and rent it out do mainstream lenders
typically do rent out and buy
option or is it quite a niche process
and would a specialist
mortgage broker be better um stud
absolutely can if you've got a house and
you want to
rent it out and then you want to move on
and rent another one
you just need to get permission from
your mortgage lender to rent it out but
typically they'll give you permission
if you just say to your mortgage lender
hey i want to move out
but i can't sell it because i need to
move out quickly i don't want it to be
empty do you mind giving me consent to
rent it out though i usually say yes
it's really not complicated it's very
straightforward if i've understood what
you're talking about
bradley taylor says i'm looking to use
the brr strategy for the first time
with 70 to 100 000 pounds capital
to use what would you recommend i
already own my own home and this will be
as a limited company
so what would i recommend well firstly i
would recommend
finding an area where you're going to do
this so finding a patch
i would recommend speaking to estate
agents and telling them what you're
wanting to do
i would recommend um you basically to do
brr
you only need to be able to calculate
three figures you need to be able to
calculate
purchase price so you need to go to find
cheap properties number two is you need
to be able to calculate how much it's
going to cost
to refurb them and then number three is
you need to know how much the gdv is
going to be the end value same as the
guy that was asking me about the land
and i said to him right so you're buying
the land for 265
the refurb development cost or to fix
the japanese knotweed it's going to be
60 grand i need to know how much it's
going to cost to build the houses and
then the gdv
it's just straightforward if you're
doing a small deal and you're starting
with 70
000 pounds or whether you're starting
with 7 million pounds you're doing a big
deal
you need to be able to calculate those
three figures so i would i would i would
spend time
educating yourself reading books finding
other property investors and builders
and building your network
speaking to estate agents telling people
what you're wanting to do
and i wish you all the best last
question
leo says how do you secure
a zero deposit option and a four week
rent free from a vendor can you explain
how i could negotiate with the vendor
on the above such that i secure a rent
to rent hmo
deal thank you okay so i think what
you're saying is you're trying to get a
rent to rent deal
but you want the owner of the property
to give you
no to charge no deposit and to take no
rent for four weeks how do you do that
i'm guessing it's because you haven't
got any money to put down
right um which is fine
congratulations for being creative how
you do it is in business
it's a free market we have a free market
in the uk which is a great thing
that means that as long as you have a
willing buyer and a willing seller
we're all good within reason some
industries have got regulation
to stop products being sold that are
faulty or dangerous
but if you're trying to negotiate with a
landlord if the landlord's happy and
you're happy
it's fine so the question rather than
you saying how can
i get free rent how can i get no deposit
what you've got to ask what you're going
to ask yourself is what can
i give the landlord
that's going to be valuable and
attractive to him what can
i do how can i help
and when you find ways to add value
in the marketplace then similarly when
you help other people get what they want
as
zig ziglar says you get what you want
so to answer your question i would be
i'll be listing all the things
the benefits of your service to these
landlords
so why would they want to give you free
rent well you could say look i will
spend the first four weeks
um fixing all the skirting boards
cleaning it up and i'll oh for free
i will do um give the property a lift
i'll paint it
and i'll bring it up to scratch and then
i'll
put tenants in and i'll give you a
guaranteed rent
where you can have live at peace and
receive a passive income but in exchange
i want a rent-free period for four weeks
and
i don't want to have to pay a deposit
what do you say
you see so so it's about thinking how
can you add value
it's the biggest tip i could give you in
business people that win in business
and that's what people um get annoyed at
rich people you know a lot of people
don't like rich people some people don't
even like me
they get upset with me because i make a
lot of money you're
stealing the houses off the poor people
um
we just did um a tour of pub conversion
with one of my students called ryan
and and people were so upset oh you're
stealing the pubs it's like no
the pubs are run down and they've been
empty for
years and now the pubs the pub owners
are saying we need to sell because this
has been closed for years and it's
falling to rack and ruin
and then an investor comes along and
says look i'll buy off you
and turns it into nice accommodation
and provides more accommodation to the
economy
bringing down the price of rents because
when there's more houses it brings down
the price of rents which makes housing
more affordable it's a really good thing
but so many people are getting upset
you're stealing the pubs
you know people um really don't
understand
business people that say they don't
understand business because business is
about
adding value willing seller willing
buyer
fair exchange that's what business is
so i really hope that you become
successful in business because that
means that you'll be bringing
you'll be boosting the economy if you
become a successful property investor
you become a successful property
entrepreneur as a deal sourcer
well that means you're providing good
deals for investors
which means that the investors are
providing a good accommodation for the
tenants
so the more you win the more i win and
that is why i'm going to keep doing a
video every single day
and that is why i'm going to keep
helping you and answering your questions
so put your questions in the comment box
i'll answer next week
if you enjoyed this video hit the like
button subscribe to the channel
that's the first step you want to be
financially free and property
subscribe to the channel on samuel's
youtube channel and i look forward to
seeing you guys next week all the best
god bless
[Music]